what would you say to the people that I
and I think this is usually people
coming from a religious perspective that
would just say don't tamper with you
know it's really the god verse science
argument don't tamper with our god-given
whatever now I get it you're not a
believer but what do you think is the
best way to argue that point for someone
that that believes that humbly and and
truly you know I actually because I was
raised a Catholic and have you know
studied the Bible essentially and I have
a degree in philosophy it's actually
partially religion as well and I would
try to argue from the the biblical point
of view which said you know it's it God
is giving us these technologies God if
if you believe in God is giving us these
ability to do these things to ourselves
I think it's something that if we can do
it it was destined by that higher power
and so I say you know why should you be
afraid of technology that is part of
God's world embrace it it's just part of
that system and actually this works
really well I mean doesn't work very
well when I talk about the chip because
they everyone thinks oh it's mark of the
beast and this and that I've got the
Antichrist you know comments so often
right but I think when you're talking
about CRISPR genetic technology if you
say to somebody I'm gonna cure your
child of leukemia with this technology
and that was God's plan all along to
make your life better then I think a lot
of people say you know what I'm willing
to accept that I think if you talk about
a fourth arm or you know some kind of
horse body that's when it goes too far
right but if you can use this stuff for
the greater good most people doesn't
matter how fundamental they are
especially when it concerns the health
of loved ones are gonna be on board and
that's good yeah does that show you how
sort of our brains in our hearts or
sometimes just not connected which your
the CRISPR is probably working on
combining those things because that I
you know sometimes I'll see some of
these politicians that you know that are
totally you know against the woman's
right to choose and I don't I am NOT a
lover of abortion but I would allow the
woman to choose what she wants to do but
at the same stabbed or ssin and then at
the same time it's like you know it
end of the day if their own daughter got
raped they would figure out a way for
their daughter to get an abortion so
there's a disconnect between sort of
what's going on it intellectually and
what's going on in the heart and a lot
of what you're talking about I think is
combining those two things a hundred
percent and I think you know what's
happening is we are as a species
improving our ability of reason and
that's something that is happening we
are are we ok the election year aside no
but we are slowly becoming a more a less
religious Society in a more reasonable
society I do believe and I think when
you look at some of the statistics
science and technology are infiltrating
our lives enough to make us say you know
we really can't believe anymore in a
Noah's Ark because that just would have
been sort of impossible I know some
people still do but broadly speaking you
can most most Christians wouldn't say
I'm gonna you know firmly say I believe
in that anymore they will they still may
firmly believe in Jesus and whatnot so
we are growing and I think the idea is
to continue down that path and hope that
one day we come to a society that is
much more spiritual based because I like
spirituality actually spirituality is
great without the fundamentalism and
that way we can see more clearly we can
have a reason based spirituality that
still incorporates all the elements of
faith and whatever without the ones that
without the ones that kind of create all
the chaos in the world yeah and that
disconnect yeah it sounds a lot like the
book by Sam Harris who's one of my what
about you oh the books right there yeah
Sam Harris we hung up but yeah I quoted
I quoted often oh there you know a guide
to spirituality without religion so have
a spiritual life you're not against that
for all the logic that you believe in
but not attached to the dogmatic yeah
stuff that can't be proven so my last
question to you I think is is the big
one about all this and I'll slightly
quote one of my favorite movies contact
when Matthew McConaughey who plays a
preacher in it and they're trying to
decide whether they're gonna go to you
know Vega to this distant star or not
and he's talking about technology and he
was really fighting against it he was
saying you know is all of this stuff
making us happier at the end of the day
you can eat quicker and you can talk
someone on the phone and all this stuff
but is it making us happier do
think that at the end of the day that
our net happiness is actually any higher
or lower than it was 200 years ago so
you know it's it's I'm a tough person to
ask that question to because I just
don't put that much
I guess credibility in happiness I put
it in much more satisfaction of
something else like what I make of my
life I really like work work for me is
everything you know the passion of what
I create with my hands my career those
are the ways that i satisfy myself
happiness is such for me a very nebulous
term and because you know is having
study philosophy there's this great you
know this great question that says if
you could be made a hundred percent
perfectly happy and put in a box and
shot into space for eternity would you
do it and almost nobody says that nobody
wants to be perfectly happy because it
like it goes against the core of value
systems that we like to have which is
it's got to be a bit of pain and
suffering and all this built in the
system but there's there's other avenues
that we do pursue like satisfaction of
life and of our careers and families and
in relationships so whether we're happy
or not isn't the most important question
I would say we're probably not we're
probably less happy than we've been
before not that dramatically much but I
mean who isn't who and at least in
America it doesn't work because the only
million hours and it I have mortgages
and this and that and the phone's never
going off my kids and diapers a change
you know I'm overwhelmed right I'll see
you so happiness is not what I'm after
but in the end of the day I do believe
something's being accomplished and
that's a very deep sense of satisfaction
and I think that's what technology is
also doing to us we're evolving so far
that we're realizing wow we are actually
becoming more than human we're becoming
almost godlike we're becoming these
these amazing entities that can not just
discover the stars but maybe even one
day merge with the Stars become AI that
spreads through the universe and that is
something that I think is incredibly
enticing and incredibly it really speaks
to my heart on what's possible of the
human being yeah
well I have to tell you I thoroughly
love this conversation because it's such
a synthesis of the things that I love
most which are all this science stuff
and future stuff and the political part
I like the sign itself a little more
than the political all right well what
do you say we do this every two years
we'll do this I assume we can live
forever at this point right I'll let you
up I'll send you the tech yeah yeah so
we'll do this every two years for say a
hundred years and see where we're at
absolutely you know from that one day
you know and then we'll do like a little
you know montage and they'll be like the
robots old eventually and this that the
little computer in front you one day
doesn't even have the body
it'll Jason will just be hologram
exactly on different planets yeah yeah
no I would love that yeah no that sounds
great all right but very cool so I want
to thank Zoltan Istvan and you can find
out more about him and the transhumanist
party at Zoltan Istvan calm
you